[Music]
in my bad no let's a bit about Jake a
new kid fan hey new kid yeah nice to
meet you hi dollars yeah yeah you got me
yeah I should never show my gum myself
am i doing it no you can't I think it's
just some mouth structure mmm Tanya
Doyle I got to Ritalin my professor has
been suspended after accidentally
leaving erotic stories in his research
project oh you crazy
robotic expecting books mm sexy books in
his [ __ ] research project I think
it's nothing it's highly possible sounds
like a briefcase and you kind of stuff
everything and you get filed in is he
creating an erotic novel and he [ __ ]
up his father come Oh sixty shades of
grey shade of dick I should have been a
girl dude no no I'm great
Justin gay I would have been the big
[ __ ] that protected all you
[ __ ] yes my job already are oh
that's my role we would have been
beefing you are the big me no you're not
though you're a prefix on the outside
but you have a very very clear under to
my carburetor and there's no girl and
there's no guy there I'm always like why
you talk to Nora oh really yeah but
you're not putting on the inside yeah
everyone knows that well I think I just
go based off of my height and just ditch
face and I'm like that got me this how
many parts you're gonna say that's
what's gotten me this far you're not the
big [ __ ] so this professor his name is
Alan he is a construction management
professor at Bowling Green University in
Ohio so I was part of like civil
engineering or something it'll be gone
next
oh gee I said that yeah it was a long
time ago that JK dude anyways back to
the Spencer
so what he did is he accidentally left
erotic stories that were included in a
batch of computer files that he returned
to the state department of
transportation at the end of a research
project
perfect yeah so when they're looking
over this this USB drive there
like what he put his throbbing dick
inside of her what so apparently he yeah
I think the pulse of that [ __ ]
in a Saracen budget listen to what this
says nobody to wrap the velcro maybe
like they're good what's funny already
perfect this is electrical enjoy your
bicycle oh wow that's super proud yeah
she doesn't give a [ __ ]
she's IQ so fat I literally look like a
Sikh a model I'm still not good enough
my speaking models are cooking huh
I know Daniel Henney said something
becky why I don't know I just think you
gotta tighten that you're going to do
that what he is having you will give it
really I have to look perfect the
Transportation Department program
administrator found seven pages of
narrative quotes that describe sex acts
involving adults children and animals oh
you know wrong more erotic stories were
later found on his laptop and along with
evidence of deleted stories and erotic
videos I don't know how to jack off to
an erotic story like how do you hold a
book while you beat off it's difficult I
think it's for women it's for him better
than he writing it for so he's an artist
right so what he is saying is quote it
is possible that I copied it and put it
in it's possible I probably did that a
few times
well he also said everybody has personal
stuff I didn't do anything that's
school I don't consider this illegal for
me it's just entertainment for a short
period of time or entertainment for
whatever so the reason live he got
suspended is because he used the
school's property oh [ __ ]
you got to watch porn on your own laptop
exactly that's true that's hard I mean
yeah I know everyone has their own it
gets hard but when it involves like
stories of children and she's like
animals watching more children than
animals
what know for sure but and animals too
that's friggin weird I would keep my
work computer work phone clean if I was
yes why are people so lacs about that
[ __ ] dude
there's perfect nobody using public
talking like a cobra like if you're a
police officer like let's say you can
surf the web with that [ __ ] computer
console you want to be looking at porno
in your cop car just use your personal
cell phone Yeah right like grandma porn
screens bigger on the cop car but then
once you change cars or something so
much fun Jerry Tillery
we had the real picture history you know
big 12 oh man I always wondered who is
into the erotic story because my friend
said that his uh he caught his dad
because not explorers know those are
romance novels there's a difference
between erotic stories reason erotic
story then it's more like watching Nolan
I don't know romance novel is the one
that you see at the grocery store with
like a girl always in distress and like
a big like Conan the warrior kind of guy
holding a girl or some things you know I
have your honor
well I guess there are two different
styles I thought it was the same thing
too he was shoving his dick in my
romance novel and one is an erotic story
erotic story is just like - Fifty Shades
of Grey I think it's a romance novel
that is yeah a romance novel she was
erotic that when I bought the products
of erotism
I don't think I could jack off to a book
though me neither me neither
I'm a visual person the most I can do is
comics hentai they have really good
stories
I need images right so when you're
reading the comics are you reading while
you're jacking off yeah how do
concentrate yeah why not uh this is
before the time of born so I would watch
it on the computer so you know it gets
tricky but I learned how to masturbate
with my left hand
yogi mouse ah you're like oh my god it's
intense and then like right when it's
about the bus you [ __ ] because what
guys do is they try to time the bus with
the bus in the video but back in a day
it was all images so you try to time the
bus to the story and then you take ages
regions load up one page or one image
it's sidon you click next page that's
why Joe was talking about when you're
masturbating and then you're trying to
bus one day bus and all of a sudden you
see this guy sleep ah totally ruins it
but they have great stories though
imagine like just you know it's a
regular story of a guy that's a loser in
high school and then like he's trying to
be the coolest guy but then like he
really likes this hot girl or something
like that and the girl doesn't really
notice him and then like but then the
girl next door she's not that hot but he
finds out that this hot girl was [ __ ]
the teacher or something like that and
in the girl next door comes back from an
ACO makeover she's hot and now they're
in love and they thought it's like cool
it's just a regular movie but they have
the scenes that is hentai anime you are
a porn connoisseur I don't like the
[ __ ] aliens and octopus [ __ ] a
girl that's just weird yeah when people
think hentai they think of a crazy [ __ ]
like [ __ ] demons [ __ ] a girl I'm
old school man
princess suicide I'm old school old
school tell me the human stories but
then you got big-ass titties in a little
ass boy I said the biggest booty yeah
this is one that I read it was really
good liking it
he's a photographer right and he's a
photographer for swimsuit girls and he's
looking for the perfect boobs so he's
you know he lives in the country and he
decided to pursue his photography
passion he really needs to go out to the
big city and he tried photography like
photographing all
these girls with different boobs but he
just says you know what it's not right
so when you went home to visit his mom
again you saw the girl next door and she
was in the pond in the rice paddy
[ __ ] with and she grew is she matured
and her boobs were perfect and he was
like oh my God where have you been all
this [ __ ] my passion was right always
here at home and almost over here so I
love the symbolism it's kind of like all
these people they try to like look for
happiness elsewhere but it's absolutely
the perfect picture at home as they get
to jack off for having tears it's
profound
dude it's profound yes man you guys
don't even know it's profound that's
hard up like having different types of
steak sometimes you want the good to
ative hamburger which is cook well quick
but sometimes you need to let me know
yeah
and afterwards are done it that was a
great story but I can't share with
anybody like a movie you know because
I'll - you shared it with everything at
all but that was like years ago oh I was
too ashamed back then that's me what
embarrassment was it was a good story
with some other people I hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if it's your
first time here welcome please subscribe
we're going to give you more videos like
this one
[Music]
[Music]